all right
so very exciting uh we're here at khan
academy with the team and we have some
students from khan lab school as well uh
with uh the i'd say legendary francis
ford coppola uh
most known for filmmaking uh i you know
obviously the godfather movies
apocalypse now patton uh i think by the
time you're gonna be the outsiders
outsiders yes um
you
have more academy awards than most of us
um
uh but but not just i think the one
thing that we're all gonna learn today
is uh as much as francis is a legend and
knows so much and and is so steeped in
film that his interests go well beyond
film uh obviously uh wine now and other
things
maybe a good place to start since
you are known as so much as as a
legendary filmmaker is how did you get
into that what was your what was your
arc from maybe being the age of some of
these students at khan lab school you
know middle school to eventually
becoming a filmmaker
well for some reason my father who was a
classical musician
uh moved every eight months it seemed
and we were always in a new house in a
new neighborhood and i was always the
new kid at school
and my name was francis
so there was other girls then
so i got all of the typical hazing when
you're the new kid
but i was i was very good at science i
was very interested in science and
electricity and i used to love to read
the lives of the inventors
and i and i felt i knew all about that
so much to this extent that when my
father asked me what i wanted to be
would i grow grow up i said a nuclear
physicist and he said to me francis you
can't flunk algebra three times in a row
and be a nuclear physicist and i said
why not
but nonetheless i was discouraged
that i could ever be
a scientist which is what i wanted to be
because i was not good at math
so whenever i went to a new school you
were very strong in geometry i was very
i was i won the geometry medal yes so
it's not i was really good at job but
geometry you can see and and you can
see that you can see the hole all the
time sometimes it's not clear but you
see it all
and i was good at that
but um so whenever i went to a new
school
i would always head to the theater
department because they always needed
people who were good with
electricity and technology and and also
that's where the girls were
and i wanted to meet them
so i figured if i was you know around
the theater department working i would
get to meet the girls
i could have also gone to the football
team where they had girls but i didn't
qualify for that
an interesting note that to understand
me
is that when i was nine years old i was
paralyzed with polio
which was a big epidemic in 1949
and it struck kids and many many many
children
were
paralyzed until
only a few years later i think in 1951
52 they developed a sec
salt vaccine and the sabine vaccine but
but my generation polio was the scary
children's disease and i got it
and i i missed the sixth grade because i
couldn't walk
but through the wonderful auspices of
the
march of dimes it was a a charity called
the march of dimes everyone donated
dimes to it and they sent a
therapist
who
slowly brought me back to the ability to
walk about a year and a half later
wow
and i mean so how did you go from you
know that state that you're talking
about where you're a little bit involved
in drama and theater to actually
deciding that you wanted to be a
filmmaker and actually making films
well i had an older brother five years
older who was very good student and very
handsome and very accomplished and
wonderful to me by the way and
i just want to be like him in fact
he was already interested in writing
stories and his name was august floyd
coppola and i just thought that was so
cool
that i i made my own name francis ford
copa just to imitate him
uh although your it was not part for
ford is my middle name but but i used it
because my brother had you i was i was
born in detroit and i my middle name was
after henry ford because my father who
was a classical musician played for the
detroit symphony and in those days they
were the big orchestras were on the
radio that was the ford hour
and so is your brother how was so how
did that tie into well i just want to do
what be like him if i could you know
when you're five years apart there's no
contest of you competing he can beat you
up he's smarter than you i mean but he
was so kind to me and encouraged me
that um i thought if he had he was so
good at school that the family thought
he was going to be the first
doctor in our italian american family
and
so i thought i would be an eye doctor so
i could work with lenses and prisms
because i always
loved prisms and what light can do in a
lab so later in college he flipped and
became a philosophy major and told my
father he was going to be a novelist
so then i said well i'll be a playwright
then
and so when i went was ready in high
school to be
considered college i thought i would try
to become a drama major
and
eventually i entered school as a
playwriting major but i of course worked
in the in the technical part of of the
theater doing the lighting and stuff one
day when i was up on a ladder hanging a
light i saw the teacher who was always
the director the shows were always
directed by faculty members
and i saw the teacher telling the kid
the actors oh you go here you go i could
do that
and so in college i started to direct
plays and
ultimately i was going to try to
you know be a writer and director in the
theater and in the theater in our
country the the great theater graduate
school there are actually several great
ones but one of the great ones is the
yale drama school which is a graduate
school so i was going to be
go right to the yale drama school and
one afternoon i was in
around the plaza of the college i pretty
much just hung around the drama
department that was my life
and i noticed a little theater that said
today four o'clock
screening of sergey eisenstein's film 10
days that shook the world
i never heard of sergey eisenstein
and it was a silent film but i had
nothing to do and i went in and there
were about maybe six
other people in the theater no one
was that interested and it was truly
silent and it lasted almost four hours
and i had never seen a film like that in
my life that the editing itself made up
for the fact that there was no sound
when they shot machine guns you could
hear them just by the way it was edited
because this eisenstein who was a film
director in the 20s invented and came up
with new ways of of cutting film
together
which is
spoken of in his era as montage
the the the curious thing that you could
take a shot
and cut it next to another shot and it
means something different than either of
the shots it's a kind of magic
alchemy and i was just so
impressed with that that i said i'm
not going to the
yale drama school i want to go to ucla
film school and i changed my whole life
and went on to be a film student in
america at a time when no film student
had ever gotten to make a feature film
so that raises the question how what was
it about either the the mindset that you
took to it or how you developed yourself
or or even just fortune that put you in
the right place that that allowed you to
do that you just described a lot of
students weren't able to make a feature
film
oh well you know in in college in the
drama department i became
very machiavellian do any of you know
what that word means you all know that
machiavellian is was a minister uh
he was actually on the outs with um
the prince in
florence and his name was nicola
machiavelli so he wrote a little book
about
a handbook for princes and you know how
to double cross people and how to do all
those what we now call machiavellian
things that there was more to him than
that but he's famous for that little
book the little book you can read in
about two hours it's called the prince
and it's all the rules of
doing all those political things i
became very machiavellian in college
because
i wondered why only the faculty members
got to direct all the plays and no
students and so i did a little research
and i learned that the plays were paid
for
by the fees the students paid upfront
for so-called co-curricular activities
or extracurricular in other words the
yearbook or the
the the newspaper or the drama
department those were all considered
like clubs
and they were funded by student fees
there were two clubs when i went to
college uh at hofstra college which is
where the the debate that um
mrs clinton and mr trump had two debates
ago was hofstra that theater that they
were in i know backwards
but so
what i did is i became the president of
both the musical comedy club
and the drama club which were very
different kinds of kids but i became
president of both and i merged them
together
and then having merged them together i
made a rule
that
you couldn't be in a show
to act in a musical or a play unless you
had not missed the club meetings or at
least you couldn't have met missed three
in a row because no one ever went to the
club meetings
so and then but i did a good thing with
it we had the meetings but i also
invited everyone who wanted to to do a
little experimental workshop or a little
one-act play so the meetings were good
but during the meeting i had a vote and
passed a rule that faculty members could
not direct shows that were funded by
student money
so suddenly all these drama teachers who
had come there so they could direct the
big show
couldn't direct it so i was the only
student who wanted to direct
so i didn't actually run for president
of two separate clubs and enact those
rules with that in mind that i will get
enough support by forcing people to go
to these meetings in two clubs to become
to allow myself to direct the shows well
it's a funny thing about power you very
you
you don't necessarily know that you're
amassing it but you sort of do
but i was going in that direction and it
worked very well for me because i got to
do uh not only could i direct the
production but i use the strength of the
that having the finance which was coming
from the club to we did ambitious show
we did original musicals we did a
production of streetcar named desire we
did all these wonderful and and many of
the things were wonderful that
brought life to to the drama department
uh because of it
and how did you so in college you get
this great experience you're directing
uh sounds like big productions how did
that translate you know when you first
did you know your first movies you did a
screenplay for patton well i went to the
ucla in those days there were two or
three big film schools there was ucla
and usc
and in new york there was nyu to make it
more clear for you marty scorsese went
to nyu
george lucas went to usc
and i went to ucla
and no one from any film school had ever
made a feature movie ever
so
you know i sort of went to ucla with a
big advantage because i had been a
theater student
and a theater student one of the you
know fundamental things a theater
student has to learn
is about writing and acting
well
writing and acting are the magical
ingredients of any
theater or cinema performance you could
see a movie and it could have beautiful
photography and it can have great art
direction but if it has terrible acting
and a dumb script it's not going to be
successful yet
a film that has a wonderful script and
wonderful acting that has terrible
photography and terrible art direction
and everything else can be a hit so
i always say that
acting and writing is the water and is
the oxygen oxygen and hydrogen that make
water
that if you if you focus on the writing
and the acting of course you want the
music and the photography everything to
be beautiful
but those are really where the magic i
think happens
so having come from theater i
knew a lot of a lot more about acting
than any of the cinema students who were
much more into the camera the great film
director orson welles once said that you
can learn everything about how to make
movies in a weekend
meaning the camera the editing and more
or less of course that's a little
overdoing it he when he made his first
film had a great photographer but
nonetheless
it's somewhat true the camera and stuff
is not the hard part the hard part is
the writing and the acting
so having done focused on that in
theater i had an advantage when i went
into the film school because there were
philosophy student terence malik was a
philosophy student
um there were
they they were crazy to get their hands
on cameras
and i had already worked with actors so
and also there's a side of prejudice
against actors in
i don't know if you know what i'm saying
but there's a sort of jock mentality
about actors among the film crews they
think oh my god they're such a
you know i mean what do they do after
well what an actor does is really hard
because if you play a violin
not only do you have to be able to play
the violin you've got the violin be the
pro between you and the audience the
actor has to sort of do what like a
violinist does except his instrument is
himself or herself so it's really
terrifying to be an actor and
uh at the same time fight the
self-consciousness that anyone would
have so i always approached movies and
theater with tremendous respect
for the actors and and the the actors we
actresses today like to be known as
actors because it comes from the
the verb to act
it's the one who acts
not that you act a role
which it indirectly means but it's the
actor means that the principal person
making movement within the story could
be a man or a woman could be an actor
so actress is sort of like professor
ressa you know lady professor it's
it's diminutive
um so at any rate i had this advantage
of having been a drama student and also
having been enough machiavellian that i
could conspire
which is what you have to do to get a
movie off the ground certainly in those
days
to try to conspire to put together a
movie which i did and i got to be and
because i was the first student to
really make a feature film
some other students from usa heard about
this weird guy
notably george lucas who was about four
years five years younger than four years
younger than me
and so he kind of came around a skinny
kid with a beard when i was directing a
picture
at warner brothers and this kid is
watching me everyone on the show was old
and wore suits
here's a skinny kid with a beard and i
looked at him looking at me and i said
well what do you see and he said not
much
and with that we became friends
immediately
and we started hanging out together and
ultimately he became sort of an
assistant he wouldn't say that now but
because he he was younger and i've known
george lucas throughout all of his
career produced his first
movies like thx 1138 and american
graffiti before he went off on his own
to do the
astonishing work that he did
and he's remained my friend he's he's
one of the few directors who still lives
more or less in northern california i
think solomon knows him
and did i answer your question no
absolutely but you know just following
up on george is something you just told
me which i found fascinating but the
more i hear your story i'm connecting
dots um he to
you aren't just known for writing and
directing these great films there's also
a famous character in popular fiction
that is based off of you yeah
that's han solo
because george felt that i was
that i just took crazy reckless chances
and would jump off the mountain without
knowing what was down there to land on
and that i would end up with no money so
he created
you can look it up say francis coppola
han solo and you'll
you'll find that so i'm sort of the
dashing failure
dude how do you do you agree with that
do you see yourself in han solo
well i know what you know george is what
i used to call i always call an old
stick in the mud because george is very
conservative although his imagination is
wild
but in his personal life he's pretty
conservative and i'm the opposite i'm
much more
i'm not afraid of
taking chances and taking risks because
you we so far what we know you get this
one life
and the worst thing that could possibly
happen when you're this old old old man
or old woman to say
be there getting ready to die saying oh
i wish i had done this i wish i had done
that i wish that's that's
you don't want to do that in my case i'm
going to say oh i got to make movies and
i got to see my kids make movies and i
got to make wine and i got to do
experimental work and i'm going to be so
busy talking about all the things i got
to do that when i die i'm not going to
notice it
and that's my recommendation
so and i think that that connects to
another thing that um it's pretty
obvious when people hear you but above
and beyond this i mean learning itself
and i think this is a connection between
yourself and what we try to do here at
khan academy you know at its core
learning is a bit of a passion of yours
in and of itself well it totally makes
sense i mean in life there are many
wonderful things you can do very many
pleasurable things many of them
unfortunately have a bad side if you
drinking wine and and alcohol in
moderation can be can be a wonderful
thing but too much will make you sick
or anything you do that brings pleasure
if you think girls are great and you're
running after girls then your wife is
gonna i've been married 53 years so
i know the value of having having one
one wife for a lifetime
uh but you you know so you can't do that
so
you know if you eat too much you'll just
get disgustingly fat which i have a uh
problem with but but
but in life learning is is as much a
pleasure as any of those things and
there's no bad part there's no
it doesn't bite you back you can't learn
too much and over oh i've overlearned
this month i just don't feel well
the only thing i know like learning like
that is music i don't know any
way unless maybe if you're listening to
ear drum breaking rock and roll where it
could be bad but music is generally good
for you
and we can talk about that because
there's a philosophy that believes
that music is the only way that we can
really understand
uh what's really out there beyond our
senses
any rate so so so learning i i always
thought when i was a little kid if they
said to me you know from francis you're
about to learn about this and about that
you're going to learn about algebra and
algebra comes from the arabs it was
called algebra and they probably learned
it from the greeks and it's really an
exciting way to say no one ever told me
at the beginning of my education what a
lot of joyous fun it was it always had
me scared that i was gonna get that
visit from miss hinchman to my father
and then i would get a uh you know in
those days there was you got hit if you
got bad report cards which i did
uh so so but no one ever told me the the
exciting side of of learning and that
not only that i used to how much
school am i gonna
you never at school i'm 77 and i learned
so much
every night i'm now i'm learning about
genetics which is really fascinating
about the human genome and the
chromosomes and the genes and it's
amazing to know that the scientists
didn't even understand it really
until the 80s
i mean that's reason some of you were
probably
well not you guys but some of you were
born in the 80s and imagine they didn't
even understand how the how the gene
worked
and they don't entirely now well that's
what i'm learning about now and it's
it's thrilling it's so exciting and
or to learn about history and
understand really you know we all know
that the world is troubled
uh and that a lot of it focuses on
uh the middle east and islam but no one
knows that really you have to go back
almost to the first world war to
understand the
bad feelings that were engendered at
that time
and
and also that islam is not uh islam was
the
the the zenith of of uh intellectual uh
study and science in the 13th section uh
uh 13th century
in terms of uh well it's interesting
because in islam you have to pray five
times a day and you have to point when
you pray towards mecca
so it was to their advantage to really
understand time so they knew they
would pray at the right time each day so
they studied the heavens to be masters
of time and the reason that
islamic science knew so much about the
heavens and time
uh
was for that reason you know it's
because they
and they want to point in the right
direction so they brought so much to us
in these areas of uh astronomy
and uh navigation
of course the the
islam the those states were close to
ancient greece so they preserved a lot
of the knowledge that had been in greek
and that's how we still have
uh such things you know as algebra yeah
and before we open it up for some
questions from from the audience how did
how did we get connected what what what
was your connect how did you bump into
khan academy well i ran across uh the
name and that you were gonna that you
had a course in algebra and i said
why was i so stupid that i didn't unders
i couldn't grasp algebra so i looked at
the beginning algebra course and i said
gee if i had had this i wouldn't have
failed algebra three times and i
understand no one ever explained it that
there was that this was a method for
solving problems
i always say why do i care what x means
i want to know what something that i
know
you know but no one explained to me that
it was a
it was essentially a procedure an
algorithm as you wish to learn how to
solve a problem they didn't say that to
me they just said you're in bad trouble
you're flunking algebra
and since i was not i wasn't at the
school from the beginning i was a new
kid i just
assumed i was stupid which is what they
told me yeah yeah
so
with that let's let's open it up for for
some questions
hi mr cocoa i'm karina i'm on the pop
students here you know we chatted um
thank you so much for coming this has
been educational and hilarious at the
same time outside of human genetics what
learning do you feel like you still have
to accomplish and what excites you now
about film
well what excites me about film is there
are many fields that interest me i mean
history
philosophy
philosophy is the study of how to think
i mean what's better than learn how to
think because you have to realize when
these early early people occupied the
earth they didn't no one was there to
teach them anything so they had to
decide for themselves and using the
thought process of well there's earth
there's fire there's water
there's air maybe these are the basic
elements they just were using
their ability to think to uncover so
that's a wonderful feel but in terms of
film
what's interesting to me about film is
that in the last um
15 years film which used to be a
photochemical it was used to have
photographic film
that you'd put in a mechanical device
and would take a series of stills then
you had to send it to the lab and
develop it
in the last
15 years
all of the elements of filmmaking have
changed from photo mechanical and
mechanical to digital electronics so the
editing machine really is a computer now
in which you
compress the images and put it in a
computer and then you can cut them
together as you wish the camera has
become so
uh high in its quality that a digital
camera is sufficient
to take the picture which only 35
millimeter film used to be able to take
and the projector in the theaters you go
to when you go to the movie theaters
they're not they're not loading up cans
of film they're also digital and they're
possible to connect to them through
satellites so in the last 15 years
everything about
filmmaking or cinema
has changed totally to a different
technology
and my feeling is that how could that
happen
without to some degree it changed the
essence of what a what a movie is
because now it's being made so totally
differently
that perhaps there are new horizons that
wouldn't have been possible
in the old days when it was really a
piece of photographic film new things
that we can do
uh that we couldn't do before and that's
sort of personally what i'm i'm
experimenting with something i call live
cinema what is live cinema live cinema
means it's uh in my case a story
told through
uh what like a movie it looks like a
movie except the actors are actually
doing it live in that moment now we all
know that they do live television like
some of you probably saw peter pan or
the sound of music but whenever you see
a live show on television or
a soap opera or something it looks like
television it doesn't behave like a
movie yet when we see a movie on
television we know it's a movie just
even though it's coming in the same way
it looks like a movie the way the story
is told is different the shots
are telling
the action in a different way so what
i'm interested in is
learning how to
it to be cinema still that it looks and
behaves like a movie you wouldn't know
that it's
even
uh not a movie except the actors are
doing it live in that moment and to do
that
i did two workshops recently one at ucla
and one in oklahoma community college
where the school invited me to work with
their students and let me do my
my idea there as an experimental
workshop what we call a proof of concept
to see if you could do it
and
and i learned so much that i wrote a
little book that i'm just finishing
called live cinema and his techniques
and it's my hope personally that that i
would get the opportunity before i
do the final oh i got to do this i had
to do that
to get to do some live cinema it's
something i've written
i want to remind you all that i used to
be a drama counselor in a camp
when i was 17. so i used to just all
summer i first my first week i do plays
with the six-year-olds then i do plays
with the seven and eight-year-olds then
nine and ten-year-olds and finally at
the end of the summer
we'd bring the boys at 15
and the girls at 15 from the nearby
girls camp and do a musical boy was that
an experience
hi mr coppola my name is gia i work on
the sustainability team here at khan
academy it's such an honor to have you
here i'm a huge fan of your films i also
love the films with her daughters of the
ekobola i wanted to ask what kind of
advice did you give her when she was
starting out her film career and also
how did you balance your role both as
her father and as co-producer of some of
her early films thank you well sophia
was always a very um
precocious little kid she was
even at age six and seven she was
i remember i once took her when she was
i mean five or four we all had to make
on godfather two we had to go to
dominican republican and we flew in this
plane and we got off in miami and it was
really hot and
uh
humid and i said to her sophia how do
you like miami and she said it's not
miami it's your army
so i knew i was in for a ride with
sophia
but it's interesting she came to me when
she was around 21 22
and she said dad you know i'm interested
in fashion and i'm interested in fashion
photography and she's done some modeling
and designing clothes and i'm interested
in writing stories but i really want to
be a painter
and paint am i just a dilettante
and i said to her you know
parents always make the mistake of
wanting their kids to focus in on
something i'm telling you the opposite
don't focus do everything you love
because if you learn about everything
you love one day
what you're meant to do in your life
will just come into it together for you
and it will be something that makes use
of all the different things someday
you'll find what you want to do and it
will involve stories and will involve
fashion and all those things and it
turned out that a few years later she
made a short film at her
uh high school
and i could see that she had a lot of
talent so i do think that parents often
because you know we
in the past there was a terrible
depression
way before uh in the 30s
but people were traumatized that their
kids needed to study something they
could make a living with
and you know the the best way to do that
is just
don't special i think
the people may disagree but don't
specialize too young because
being interested in one thing might stop
you from thinking you could be
interested in nothing be interested in
everything you can be
everything you love you should learn
about because then one day it will all
come together and be useful for whatever
it is you choose you want to do with
your life
and that was the case with sophia
hello i'm sam from kls and i was
wondering if you could travel back in
time to middle school would you do
anything differently
what's middle school what grade is
middle school sixth grade well six i was
sixth grade i was paralyzed in bed
watching television
watching television day and that was
before the remote control so i was stuck
i couldn't walk to change it
i was a prisoner of
mid-50s television but
you know
my school
you know i went to 22 schools before i
went to college so i
i was always i felt like an outsider i
had no friends at all
uh you don't have time to make friends
and when you're there for six months and
i always did badly so i was always in
trouble with my father i wish that i had
the
sense to say when he was coming at me
seeing my report card
with his belt folded in his hand i wish
i said but you take me out of school
every six months so how can i possibly
get good marks
so i was a sad lonely kid through middle
school
and wanted to have friends
and kept moving to different places and
when you move
as far away as like from new york to
california it's really different in
those days
l.a
los angeles was so different from new
they didn't have baseball they didn't
have comic books stores
uh they didn't have white castle
hamburgers
and and so i was just miserable at your
age i hate to say but hemingway ernest
hemingway the the writer the famous
american writer said that if you want to
be a writer you should have an unhappy
childhood so i had an unhappy
and i childhood just wondering what were
some struggles that you had
directing your first movie
well my real
first movie was a little horror film
that i made in ireland
when i was about i mean a feature film
when i was about 21
and um
you know i guess what struck me
was i always have been a person with a
lot of good ideas or a good imagination
and i would always see all these things
but when you make a film you have to
take what's in your mind and what is
your imagination and you have to find
practical ways
to do it and it's not always as easy as
you think that it's kind of what they
say in
car
terminology when the rubber meets the
road in other words the world of
imagination and fantasy is wonderful
because you have no
limits it's just as
you can just cook something up in your
mind but then to translate that into
a form that other people can see and
enjoy involves a lot of practical stuff
of scheduling and budget and
you know you're the shot you had in mind
you can't really fit it in it's not like
you thought so you have to learn
as part of the creative process to to
learn to be inventive and flexible
to to try to there's two roads there's
what you imagine and to what you can do
and you have to be the one between those
and use whatever
uh
cleverness you can to to get there so i
when i made my first film i realized
that that the practical side was really
very important or you wouldn't get the
great ideas on in the film
so you know just to close out and i
think all of us would love to sit here
all day and and continue to tour all you
know the whole week um
but just to finish off uh you know
there's some parallels between what
we're doing and things that you're
interested in and that you have
experience in especially as
you just talked about film going into a
new era with the technology obviously
we're trying to do things along those
lines in education trying to reach a lot
of folks what
advice in any form would you have to
everyone here about the students and the
members of khan academy as we go off on
our journey
well all human beings and all animals
really seem to be good at play we like
to play it's a natural thing we do
and
we have to realize that
work that we do later in life is really
a development of that so i try to keep
the work i do
as much like play as i can i can make a
quick demonstration if you want to
quickly absolutely could i have um what
can i get about
this group of kids in a circle where is
there to do that you don't want to get a
circle here go over there where we can
see you okay
this is an acting exercise all right so
no no not not that many just the ones on
there
okay how many you want well everyone's
sitting down here go make a circle over
there i would do it with everyone but i
don't see a space now make a circle all
hold your hands in a circle
okay good
now make the circle as wide as you can
come out to me right now
is that about it little more
okay now this is an acting exercise
actors
have to be very
concentrated because
they have to appear when someone says
something to them they have to make it
seem as though they're seeing it for the
first time
like if you say something in a play it's
in the script so you know you're gonna
say it but how do you do so we play a
game
uh when i work with actors i try to make
it as much fun as i can this game is
called sound ball and the way it's
played if i go like this
i have an imaginary ball right
i'm going to throw it to you
you catch it now here's the throw back
to me
okay now i'm going gonna throw it to you
but i'm gonna make a sound when i throw
it ready bop
now when you catch it you catch it with
bop
and then you throw it to me you give it
its own your own sound you want to
boo okay so when you catch it you catch
it with the sound that person threw with
you and this is to teach actors
concentration to because they don't know
when
when a line is going to come to them all
right so here we go
can you do it throw the ball to him
throw the ball to anyone you want baby
make a sound
catch it with the sound
and throw it with another sound
you got to do it a little faster
go ahead
can you do it faster
don't make it hard make the sounds clear
so they can do it now what we're going
to do is we'll do the same thing and go
a little faster and i'm going to throw a
second ball in oh it's really hard ready
i'll start it ready
bop
up
ding bang zip
boop
you do once more but you get the idea
you have to be aware if you're an actor
you have to be aware and not look like
you're aware but if someone's going to
throw you the ball you want to be there
to catch it you ready i'm going to do it
again
nope
you get the idea
you very much
but there are a million acting games
that call theater games that we could
play
and whenever possible if you can work
and develop something that you want to
develop like in this case concentration
it's better to do it in the form of play
because then the day becomes fun so i
try to make
all the work
especially creative work because that's
so much fun as you know
as much play as possible awesome well
thank you thank you so much i think this
is going to be a huge treat this was a
treat for us and i think everyone
watching on facebook and online thank
you thank you thank you